well good evening everyone a question
we're looking at is the the idea of what
evidence means or should mean in science
the standard view of course is that
science relies on evidence and on facts
but increasingly in some areas of
cutting-edge science particularly in
physics we seem to find ideas put
forward that not only lack evidence but
lack any clear way of collecting
evidence about them so ideas about
string theory for example about
multiverse is about many worlds in
quantum mechanics does this mean that
perhaps evidence needn't have the
crucial adjudicating position that it's
traditionally been given in science or
does it mean that science or this area
of science in particular is in danger of
drifting into sheer fantasy or
philosophy which I don't think of the
same things well first of all I've got
three distinguished speakers who have I
think quite different views I hope
they'll be quite different views about
this question on my right Rupert
Sheldrake who's a biologist whose
research into parapsychology and
evolution led him to formulate the
theory of morphic resonance first on my
left Terra fears who is a particle
physicist and a professor of physics at
University of Liverpool and next to her
Massimo Pigliucci and our professor of
philosophy at the City University of New
York so first of all I'm going to give
them their three minutes beginning with
Rupert
a lot of science is based on assumptions
that have no evidence in their favor in
my most recent book the science delusion
I described 10 of these assumptions
which most scientists take for granted
they don't realize their hypotheses they
have they're just assumed to be true and
these lead science into complicated
tissues of speculation I'll take first
the assumption the laws of nature are
fixed this is something built into the
foundations of science partly because of
the Platonic influence on the founding
fathers of modern science who thought
the ID laws of nature were ideas in the
mind of a mathematical God and therefore
fixed eternally and now just built into
the general platonic assumption that
most physicists and theoretic and
mathematicians have that there's a kind
of platonic mathematical realm beyond
space and time so the assumption is the
laws of nature as we know them and the
constants were all fixed at the moment
of the Big Bang then they have to
explain why were they fixed the way they
are so that we exist and so forth and
there's two main theories either some
intelligent designer fine-tuned them to
get them exactly right but since that
might involve something like God
reentering the picture the more popular
alternative is that we live in a
multiverse with countless universes that
actually exist of which we only can know
the one that's suitable for us and this
is one of the tissues of speculation but
what if the laws of nature aren't fixed
what if they're not there in an
evolutionary universe totally fixed
forever what if the laws evolved after
all law is an anthropocentric metaphor
only humans have laws it's one of the
ways in which we project our human
concerns onto the universe in the 18th
17th century it made sense God was a
kind of Emperor so if the universe is
radically evolutionary which it seems to
be why shouldn't the laws evolve because
human laws evolved or better a better
metaphor in my view is that there may be
more like habits if they like habits
that could be a memory in nature they
don't all have to be fixed at the
beginning so this whole debate about why
are they exactly right becomes a non
debate the whole of this vast issue of
space
halation evidence free speculation can
just be dissolved away by actually
asking the question are the laws more
like habits you can do experimental
tests to see if there's a memory in
nature so that's one assumption that
hasn't been tested but is taken usually
for granted another is that that nature
is purposeless this is simply follows
from the machine metaphor on which
science was based in the 17th century
machines have no purpose therefore the
universe has no purpose
evolution has no purpose the second
point I want to make in my remaining 90
seconds is that evidence the facts don't
speak for themselves you can have
evidence that's plain for all to see and
if it doesn't fit someone's theory
they'll deny it in the 18th century when
peasants saw stones fall from the sky
meteorites and describe them to the
Academy of Sciences they simply said
it's impossible these must have just
been ordinary stones as were struck by
lightning which is why they were hot it
was impossible because there are no
stones in the sky they simply denied the
evidence and the other way in which
evidence is distorted is by selective
publication drug companies are now known
to publish selectively the results that
favor their drugs and not publish the
ones that don't then evidence based
medicine which looks so impressive on
the surface peer-reviewed journals
review all the evidence then these drugs
turn out to be very good it's based on
highly selective publication of evidence
this is now endemic in science the so
called replicability crisis which was
recently in the last two or three years
cropped up something in some studies up
to 90% of papers in the biomedical
sciences and about 50% in psychology
turn out not to be replicable why
largely because people just publish
their best results and don't publish the
others because it's important to get
ahead in science by publishing good
results then we come to the problems
that my colleagues here will be talking
about the in physics where concepts like
darkman
multiverses and i put forward and widely
believed as theories but which have left
behind
normal scientific criteria of evidence
but at this stage I hand over to others
first well I like to make a distinction
between science and the scientific
method so by science I mean the clock
the collection of facts and laws that we
have used to govern behavior I don't
mean laws as in habits as Rupert has
been talking about
I mean mathematically defined precise
rules of behavior that seem to be obeyed
again again again as often as we test
them now science in that sense is our
best description of the universe from my
point of view and how it behaves because
it's a replicable one you've given
examples of bad practice in science but
I don't think they describe all science
but the scientific method is the process
by which we get to that understanding
and it's that's where evidence comes in
so the scientific method proceeds by
having a hypothesis an idea that you can
use to make predictions about the world
around you using that prediction you
design an experiment that gives you data
and that data is your evidence that you
confront against the hypothesis to see
if it fits or if it doesn't fit and
decent science if it doesn't fit should
then reject the hypothesis both inputs
are really important you need to have
theory and hypotheses to give context to
explain the data that you're seeing but
you need to have the evidence to tell
you which hypotheses describe reality
you can't have one without the other
so evidence is incredibly important in
enabling us to understand the universe
but it's not the only ingredient if we
just had evidence how would we make
sense of it
that's the point I want to make I want I
was going to give you an example of the
scientific method but being a particle
physicist I was just gonna give you a
particle physics example of the
discovery of the Higgs boson which is a
really nice example we have a hypothesis
dreamt up in the 1960s of this strange
field this energy field that permeates
throughout the universe it sounds
science-fiction Airy it's invisible it
just seals one prediction which is the
existence of a particle you should be
able to see and it took 50 years to be
able to design the experimental
equipment to actually obtain the data to
then see if that was indeed the case
which brings me on to the second point
I want to raise so we've talked about
theories that don't seem to have
experimental evidence like multiverse is
like string theory we've got to remember
that the scientific method is a
continual process our ability to find
out knowledge in advanced science is a
continual process and to do that you
have to advance your theories beyond
your current understanding to try and
understand more you have to push your
experimental facilities beyond your
current technology in order to be able
to find out more and at any stage in
that cycle you will have theories that
haven't yet progressed to the stage of
yet being testable either because they
are not mature enough like string theory
to yield predictions that are currently
testable or because they're your
predictions which experiment hasn't
caught up with to make predictions yet
and so to test those predictions yet
you're in a sort of limbo in the
scientific process at that point so I
would claim that the role of evidence
coming in defines what we would say as
science and scientific knowledge
it's the testable part and then the
scientific process a scientific method
of these examples that you've given of
theories coming in that don't have
evidence at the moment is part of our
process for extending science that's
that's my take
the the first thing I want to make clear
is for myself at least as both
philosopher of science and a scientist
this simply is no such thing as science
without empirical evidence now in
particular we can discuss what is the
relations between empirical evidence and
theory we can discuss whether you know
at one point a theory becomes not
particularly interesting as a research
program because it's not yielding
anything that can be tested so all those
things can be negotiated and they need
to be negotiated by the properly
competent scientific community you know
I'm a biologist I'm not gonna tell the
string theorist well you waited long
enough dudes move on right they're gonna
be the ones to decide when that time has
arrived but I think that it is simply
non-negotiable that empirical evidence
no science without empirical evidence
and there's no science more particularly
without a good match between the
empirical evidence and the theory but
that's one of the things that probably
will be to have to flash out now often
we have this issue of scientists or some
scientists at least are dogmatic well
yes and no there's two ways of looking
at the issue of dogmatism here on the
one hand there are certain things that
have been so well-established and so
well understood that yeah I'm gonna be
go mad about it if somebody tells me you
know Darwin was fundamentally wrong
natural selection is not a real process
in nature I'm just not even gonna look
at that person because that is something
that has been established over a hundred
fifty years plus experimental results
theory and so on and so forth I'm simply
not I don't have the time to renegotiate
it okay but if you're telling me well I
don't think string theory is
well-established them sure of course
yes that's true and in fact the relevant
epistemic community that is this
fundamental theories themselves are
actually not in agreement on what's
going on there so I'm gonna wait until
they figured it out that's one sense in
which scientists can be dogmatic the
other sense is science scientists can be
dogmatic
in the sense that they can be resistant
to new ideas and sometimes improperly so
or maybe they be they can push their own
agenda their own ideas and in a way that
it's inappropriate well welcome to the
world I mean you you know scientists are
human beings whatever makes anybody
think that
they're different you know qualitatively
from the rest of humanity I mean that's
that seems to be a mistaken idea
scientists are not more objective than
other people they're not certainly not
more you know somehow capable of
deciding what that's what the truth is
about their own theories they have their
own biases we all will go the way of
every science works and it works
reasonably well at least we haven't
figured out a better way of
investigating nature so far is that
science is done by a community of people
and these people have the more varied
their cultural background gender
politics and whatever it is the better
science comes out just to give you a
trivial example until not that long ago
a lot of medical research was done you
know only on middle-aged white men
because the people that were doing the
research were middle-aged white men then
it turns out that certain aspects of
human physiology artifacts anything is
very different for women or its inventor
different for people with different
ethnic backgrounds
but that came to the fore and was
corrected only once we started having
enough women or enough ethnic minorities
involved in the process of science and
people started looking at it and what am
I missing here half of the picture
you're missing a quarter of the picture
that's the way work we don't when we
figure out a better way of doing it yet
at the moment it's science the only path
to knowledge that depends on what you
mean by knowledge I think it is the only
path to serious understanding of the
natural world i we don't have any other
way we haven't figured out any other way
of doing it you can try mystical
insights just sit in your room and think
about the universe and you won't come up
with anything worth coming up with I am
a philosopher I can do a lot of armchair
philosophizing but I will not be
discovering new facts about the world
that way
however if by knowledge he means
something broader like understanding
because as has just been pointed out but
I you know it's one thing is the facts
and the other thing is the understanding
of those facts the theories are actually
supposed to articulate and understand
of things so understanding is broader
than just than just science so we can
have other disciplines contributing to
an in particular in this case I think
philosophy philosophy of science
epistemology even cognitive science
because cognitive scientists are the
ones that actually point out the
cognitive biases that scientists
themselves suffer from as human beings
and therefore can be addressed finally
are there limits to science so sometimes
you hear these these all thing is our
but science is a limited enterprise yes
of course it is it's a human Enterprise
it's done by fallible human beings it's
done by human beings that are smart but
up to a point we can understand process
information and so on and so forth the
only opportunity to a point there's a
certain way and not only that but we are
clearly defined in our in the way in
which we think by our particular
cultural background an historical moment
okay
the reason both Darwin and Wallace came
up with with the metaphor of natural
selection because the theory is as far
as we can tell correct and it describes
the way the world is but the the
metaphor of natural selection came out
of the specific background of Victorian
England okay it's it had been done at
another time in another culture they
would have come up with a different
metaphor of a different way of looking
at things that's true everywhere all the
time if anybody including any scientist
thinks that they can transcend their own
cultural milieu they're just fooling
themselves
okay now I want to start burrowing down
a bit into the question of what it is
that we're talking about what it is that
qualifies as evidence and Rupert you
pointed out some respects in which
pressures personal and institutional and
political and social pressures can
distort the scientific agenda and can
distort the way that evidence is used
but would you accept the general
principle that evidence is looking at
what what the world tells you if you
like comparing that against predictions
that your theory makes and seeing oh
well very definitely I mean I've spent
most of my career as an experimental
scientist I mean I'm doing experiments
with doing one just a couple of days ago
I mean this is what I do and if I didn't
believe in evidence I wouldn't waste my
time doing it so I'm totally in favor of
that I mean my gripes are really about
not sufficient skepticism about
assumptions selective dismissive
dismissal of evidence corruption of the
scientific process those are the points
I'm making I'm not against evidence I
think is essential to science and as a
biologist which you know the biology is
a very empirical subject it's very
important the research I do in disputed
areas of science like research on
telepathy leads me into discussions
where these become rather crucial issues
because I've had encounters with
so-called skeptics who've told me I had
a debate at the European skeptics
Congress with a leading European skeptic
on telepathy the European skeptics
Congress yes in Brussels
yes those are not people I want to leave
you rope or anything like that
these are card-carrying members of
skeptical organizations whose main
purpose is to sort of discredit all
these it seems their main purpose is to
discredit the research research in
parapsychology anyway here I was in a
debate with the Europeans captured
Congress I spent half an hour setting
out evidence for telepathy gathered by
myself and other people to epithelia
animals telepathy and people my opponent
gave a theoretical discussion for half
an hour showing that the laws of
thermodynamics and gives free energy and
so forth would not allow this to be
possible and therefore all my evidence
was flawed so I asked him to point out
what the floors were and he said oh I
can't do that I didn't read your papers
do you think I'd waste time on that so I
mean here we have a kind of attitude
that I've encountered myself only too
often where I do research in disputed
areas of science and where there's a
taboo against this I really believe
strongly in evidence that's why I do the
research but I've personally encountered
this extraordinarily closed-minded
attitude to it so I know for me this is
a live issue is evidence important or
not and I certainly know some people who
call themselves scientists for whom it
is not important if it doesn't fit with
their worldview so but wait a minute
since I'm a card-carrying skeptic I
guess I should I've been curious first
of all who was the this person you mind
telling me was the Dutch secretary of
the Dutch Stichting skep says whose name
will come to me yeah now that's fine I
know who is okay so I'll write to him
later so okay here's the thing with
so-called card-carrying skeptics the
skeptic community is not really the same
as the scientific community there is a
number of scientists such as myself who
considered themselves skeptics in that
in that sense but they're actually two
distinct communities the skeptics as a
movement or as a set of organizations or
whatever it is they did come
about largely over the last several
decades as a way to confront what they
perceive to be pseudoscience in the
public eyes so these are actually people
were concerned about public
understanding of science they don't
usually do research on their own what
they do occasionally do very very
occasionally but they don't do they're
not professional scientists they
basically are you can think of them as a
sort of a grassroot version of public
science they rely on what scientists do
in order to inform themselves and some
of them do it well some of them of
course they're human beings so don't do
it particularly well but I don't think
one can fault them necessarily for let's
say don't taking seriously research on
telepathy or clairvoyance or whatever it
is because what they're doing is they're
looking at the pertinent epistemic
scientific community right in that case
we could be psychologists or it could be
biologists or whatever it is and they're
saying well do you guys have done
anything like this you guys think there
is any merit into that and if the
scientific community says no we don't we
don't think so then the skeptics I think
are in the proper domain of thence
essentially going to the public in
general I said look scientists don't
believe in this stuff so you should be
wary of these kinds of claims this
morning I talked about your mother the
other appearances they have done I
talked about this issue of trust right
so most people in general public simply
do not have sufficient technical
understanding of science to settle
scientific debates in their own minds
we don't I mean you know even though I'm
a scientist I am an evolutionary
biologist I cannot possibly settle the
Bates even in other areas of science you
know be it quantum mechanics or or
experimental psychology this is my
competence I should be reading a lot of
books and articles that I don't actually
understand right so that's even worse
for a member of the general public who
does not have necessarily that technical
background so it becomes an issue of
trust and when you say when it becomes
an issue of trust then you say well who
is the expert or what is who is the
expert community that I can go to and
for better or worse because the
certainty our flaws and there certainly
Eric on it there is going to be
occasional good idea that gets discarded
at least temporarily the president
epistemic community is the one that the
people should go to and say well if you
guys don't believe this or if you guys
believe this that's that's a the
opposite example is let's say climate
change right a lot of people in the
general public especially in the United
States are skeptic skeptical of climate
change that to me is a form of denial
it's not skepticism because if 97% of
climate scientists tell me yeah this
this thing is happening and it is at
least in part anthropogenically fueled
what the hell am i to say no you guys
are all wrong and I understand it better
you're bringing up a really important
point sorry I'm going to leap in here
which is the interpretation of data as
well the interpretation of evidence it's
not straightforward to analyze data
we've already mentioned that scientists
are biased like anybody else and you
have to remove that bias to the best of
your ability and make your data
objective and then it has value in
comparing two different hypotheses and
reflecting reality it's very difficult
for somebody not in your field to fully
evaluate if you have it understood your
data appropriately I think that's now
the case because we've become so
specialized so this idea of trust among
scientists what the truck that
scientists have done the right job is
tremendously important in believing that
evidence is appropriate for the
statements that are being made about it
so that's something that we shouldn't
forget as well Oh a completely agree you
have to be able to interpret evidence in
an appropriate way I think though that
máximos point you know that you just go
to the community and if they say we
don't believe this there you trust them
there are certain communities with there
are deep prejudices and taboos in all
communities and this way would be a just
a reflection a way of reflecting a
predominant taboo whenever I give talks
on topics like telepathy to scientific
audiences I have to invariably have the
experience of a fairly polite reception
sometimes there's a militant skeptic who
tries to get me disinvited before I even
speak and they boycott the lecture
that's quite common action
and then the people who come are usually
listen politely they ask a few technical
questions at the end about the
statistics and so on then in the tea
break afterwards what always happens is
that people look nice and left and they
can't see I'm so glad you talked about
this I had this experience just last
week I knew when my wife was calling and
it was just a I'm sure it was telepathic
and another one said my dog knows when
I'm coming home from the lab and and
they always say I can't tell my
colleagues because they are so straight
and they'd be so disapproving and in one
sub-department in Cambridge all six
members of staff came to me saying the
same thing that they were really
interested but they couldn't talk to
their colleagues about you
so I said to you I said to them why
don't you guys come out you know you
have so much more fun what about that
say they are real to booze
can I ask do you think it's a valid
activity to try to do experiment to see
whether there is something that seems to
be telepathic some kind of telepathic
communicator and it has been done for
more than a century right and it hasn't
convinced the relevant scientific
community and therefore at the moment
I'm gonna say no no no further research
is warranted I mean that look the idea
is that it's it's easy to paint as I
said the scientific community as a bunch
of rigid people who don't change their
mind their head they have the truth they
think that they have the truth and all
that sort of stuff but that's just not
the way the history of science shows
things work I mean if you just pick up
any book on the history of science you
will see that there is always a high
premium on discovering what everything
else thinks is not true and convincing
the rest of the community do you think
that Darwin got accepted
you know overnight when he published
this stuff do you think that Galileo got
accepted overnight I mean the guy almost
died as a result of his stuff there is a
high premium and there is a high stake
in in sort of frontier scientific
research okay but there is also a high
likelihood of failure okay whenever
you're doing something that is at the
frontier whenever you're doing something
that is at the border lines of between
science and and and the unknown more
likely than not you're gonna fail that's
just the way science works if it were
really a safe enterprise then we'd be
rather boring and we would never go
anywhere okay but the fact is there is a
high premium a high price to be done if
you actually do manage to convince the
relevant scientific epistemic community
and this has happened over and over and
over I mean the people that we just Lee
recognized as geniuses of the scientific
enterprise over historical times have
done precisely that so how would that
happen ever it's the scientific
community where that that entrenched in
their own opinions and never change the
mind and so on and so forth what is true
however is that scientists tend to be
conservative by nature and I don't mean
politically conservative I mean that it
takes a lot of evidence to convince
of something now Carl Sagan famously put
it in these terms which I'm sure
nobody's familiar with extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
Sagan who was a very smart
you know astronomer didn't actually come
up with that however he just came up
with this participant erna phrase the
phrase goes back or the concept goes
back to David Hume in the 18th century
and Hume said in an inquiry on human
understanding and in particular and an
essay on miracles of all things he said
that a reasonable person proportions his
beliefs to the evidence right so what
that means is that if I let me give you
an example so if I told you that I came
to the festival by taking a plane from
Rome and then a car from London I doubt
that anybody would seriously question my
statement because like that sounds
that's a pretty you know run-of-the-mill
kind of thing and I'm not making any
extraordinary claim you don't I don't
need to provide you with the receipt for
the airplane and all that so you're just
gonna believe me because why would the
why the hell would I lie but if I said I
stepped into my office in Rome into a
Pella Porter and then appeared right
outside the door of the festival here
you'd be a fool not to ask for serious
evidence of that sort of stuff if you
just believe me on it I have a large
bridge in Brooklyn that I can sell you
for really cheap right so so that's the
issue it and there is no clear answer
those those are the example just gave
you is clear I hope but then there is a
bunch of other situations where you just
have to negotiate it over time and it's
very possible I don't I don't exclude
that in a 50 years down the road or a
hundred years down the road somebody
would have made enough inroads on let's
say telepathy to convince the relevant
scientific community and all of this
would say and and people will point to
these kinds of discussions they see
those fools that didn't believe it right
and they're not fools they're actually
doing the right thing
never being conservative they're not
they're just being bigoted and
prejudiced and you see you say exclusion
extraordinary claims demands
extraordinary evidence to say this
billions of universes seems to me an
extraordinary claim there's no evidence
whatsoever I Dumbo and yet I read the
schedule
apart from Martin Gardner I don't see
many people objecting to that the
billions of universes it's a standard in
physics you can hold down a
professorship you can be president of
the Royal Society you can believe this
with no evidence and yet when I say
telephone telepathy about 80% of the
population claimed to have had the
experience of thinking of someone who
then rings in a way that seems to them
telepathic it's not extraordinary its
ordinary so then the question is are
these people deluded is it just
coincidence do they just forget all the
times they're wrong and stuff then you
do experiments to find out that's
whether some of the experiments I do and
how I do them if just to fill it in is
have someone sitting in a room being
filmed on camera with a landline phone
no caller ID they give us the names of
four people that they know well who they
might be telepathic with we pick one of
the callers at random ask them to ring
they have to guess who's ringing before
they pick up the receiver
I think it's John hi John they're right
or wrong the chance level is for 25% one
in four these experiments filmed
experiments published in peer-reviewed
journals have hit rates about 45 percent
massively significant more significant
than the Higgs boson actually I wanted
to ask about its significance no no this
is a really important point significant
so I'm glad we've brought it up because
it's not sufficient to just make a
measurement of something once in that
might not mean anything if you have
backgrounds if you have systemic biases
that you have to account for in your
measurement you need to repeat something
a lot of times before it becomes
significant enough to actually claim as
evidence and depending on your depending
on which branch of science you're in and
the sort of the statistical level can be
different but the example that you've
just given there my first question is a
physicist would be your normal question
from the audience that you've run this
experiment how many times what's the
statistics what are the sources of
systematic error there have you taken
them into account it's been repeated in
other labs there's a lot of evidence
when I meet psychologists from the
community that Massimo's so in
fluence PI and I say to them about these
heavens they haven't read it they just
say there is no evidence for psychic
phenomena it's all been discredited I
mean I hear that mantra over and over
again that's why I don't trust them in
their judgment in the way that Massimo
seems to
I I want to to look at these multiverses
which of which there certainly is no
evidence but I think it's probably
important also to recognize that it's
not an idea that someone has plucked out
of the air because it seemed fat you
know a nice thing to suggest that those
kinds of ideas stem from extending the
physics that we know at the moment into
realms where it becomes very hard
perhaps you know impossible to test and
there's there's a clear history of doing
this and Terry you were saying you know
this is something that needs to happen
it was in a sense something that
Einstein was doing with with general
relativity that you know he didn't come
that idea didn't come out of nowhere it
was well motivated but it took some you
know there was certainly no evidence for
it when he proposed it and it seems that
in physics in particular there is this
tradition of building on what we know
building into you know regimes where
it's not obvious how things should be
tested to you do you think that's a
valid way for science to proceed can it
run ahead of its ability to produce
evidence I do think so for the reasons I
stated at the beginning so this this
idea of physics proceeding by standing
on the shoulders of giants as Newton
were habit is important because it's how
we make progress you don't throw
everything out every generation and
start from scratch because you would
never get anywhere we we have an
understanding that describes a lot of
the universe we want to understand more
of it because we know that there's so
much out there that we don't yet
understand and that's what motivates
people to think of alternative
approaches like multiverses like string
theory it's to overcome problems in our
existing understanding of the universe
it's to try and find a solution to push
our knowledge out more now these things
are at the frontier and the thing about
physics is that it's a really simple
worldview compared to what Rupert's
studying or to philosophy which are very
complex systems potentially because you
have a lot of variables in physics we
try and slim things down identify under
four underlying laws of behavior that we
can then extend to find out more
everything that's it's the way that's
worked for us that's been very
successful so these examples that you've
highlighted are examples of our science
in progress
I don't know if they can a pan out or
not be honest do you think that what
nature tells us always has to be the
ultimate arbiter of that question the
position you you outlined at the
beginning seemed to suggest that there
was the case and I think it was probably
Richard Feynman who said you know you
can't fool nature but when Einstein came
up with general relativity and it was
put to the test by Arthur Eddington
looking at a solar eclipse when he was
told that the KIAC seems to confirm your
idea he famously said you know I knew
that it would and if the evident and and
people said well what if the evidence
hadn't supported it he would have said
oh he said I would have felt sorry for
the Lord because the theory is correct
so it seemed to emplace into in play
that he felt there was something beyond
the the physical evidence you can get
from from the world that can at least
give you confidence in sticking with an
idea do you think that's a valid thing
to do yeah there are instances of that
throughout the history of physics and
I'm thinking of Paul Dirac who combined
special relativity and quantum mechanics
to come up with an equation that
describe the motion of an electron
whatever speed it was going and his
equation had two solutions twice as many
as it should have had and so him this
equation was so beautiful in a
mathematical sense that it really had to
be real it had to describe the universe
and it's that pigheadedness thinking
that you you've hit upon a good solution
that's really reality should be fitting
in that case four years later
experimental evidence to explain what
this other solution was which turned out
to be antimatter came along and then we
saw well in that case Dirac was right
but you know that's that's not always
the case and but it wasn't just Pig
headedness indirect case was it it was a
sense that there was a beauty as he saw
it to his equations that gave it some
sort of validity and a Massimo you
you've just been to a meeting where this
has been discussed our criteria like
that
valid criteria to judge scientific ideas
when the evidence can't no they aren't
and here's what happens so what would be
talking about the last few minutes like
Einstein making that kind of arrangement
there there's a number of other examples
in the history special of physics they
tend to be physicists you know I really
here by a biologist making that kind of
claim there has to be true because my
mathematics is like that we remember
Jose because those actually turn out to
be right and we forget that there been
there will be another 90 examples at the
same time of people saying something
similar and we forget about them because
they turn out to be wrong in fact book
by least mulling that came out a few
years ago the trouble with physics is a
history of sociological history of 24
20th century physicists physics and it
lists one theory after another that at
some point in other people said this
must be true because so beautiful so
mathematically perfect blah blah blah
blah and then it turned out to be wrong
right so yes of course we want our
theories to be as elegant as the
simplest possible this is a human
criterion however this is not a
criterion imposed by nature there's
nothing that says the nature has to be
simple or understandable for that matter
right it's a we'd like it that white
because this is where static creatures
as well and and it works better for us
that why because we can understand
better we can explain better things if
it turned out to be mathematically
simple and so on and so forth but that's
no guarantee of anything and all we have
here is a simple case of what them these
psychologists will care we'll call a
selective bias that is we remember the
hits and forget the misses and that's
why we get this impression that all a
lot of scientists have actually been
guided just by this almost mystical
sense of being right but I want to go
back if you guys don't mind for a second
to the comparison between telepathy and
string theory I don't actually believe
in either one of them and I'm even
feeling uncomfortable saying using the
word belief I probably apply to those
kinds of concepts I mean do I think that
there is evidence or do I don't think
that there is evidence in the case of
string theory the case I'm sorry the
multiverse the the case the answer is
clear no there is no evidence at the
moment period so if we're just talking
about you should believe
things that are that for which you have
evidence you shouldn't believe in in the
multiverse and that's why I don't but
the difference between I think use of
the word belief I mean you can believe
what you want
I can't sure but as a scientist as I
said earlier I read a you know
proportion my belief to the evidence and
if there is no evidence about something
I simply don't believe it but don't
believe it it's not the same as
dismissing it right that's what I wanted
to get together the difference so not
believing something is simply I can be
simply agnostic about it
in fact that's that that describes that
better describes my position about the
multiverse as well that could be a
multiverse and there is interesting
reasons mathematical reasons to think
that might be such a thing but there is
no empirical evidence at the moment and
until an F that empirical evidence comes
in I am going to suspend my judgment
right the reason that situation is
different from telepathy is twofold and
it goes back to that unfortunate
behavior of your skeptic opponent he's
called oh okay so so here's I think
however where the difference between the
two cases are there are there two major
differences first of all the multiverse
is compatible and predicted by certain
interpretations of very well-established
mathematical theories that are based on
very well-established physics that
doesn't mean it's true but it does mean
that there is very good reasons to think
that it may be true on the other hand as
your scalp skeptic pointed out it is in
fact the case that as far as we
understand something like a lot of
paranormal phenomena would in fact
actually undermine a lot of our current
understanding of physics chemistry and
biology now there's nothing wrong with
that because it is possible that we
don't understand well we dramatically
misunderstand
physics chemistry and biology but now
the bar is raised okay on one hand we
have a situation which is theoretically
well compatible with what we know we
just don't have the empirical evidence
to prove it and on the other hand we
have something that actually would
undermine a lot of what we think we
understand about the world which means
that now the bar is raised higher that's
one reason for the difference the second
reason for the difference I'm sorry but
I'm going to disagree on a factual
matter researching in telepathy and
other aspect other particle
a phenomena has been conducted in
university laboratories for decades two
in particular one a Cornell University
one at Princeton both of them now have
closed for lack of results they
published a few papers here and there in
peer-reviewed journals but the majority
of scientific community look at these
things in now sorry this is can be
interpreting a number of other ways that
can be explained and um there are other
ways that don't need to invoke telepathy
that is a reasonable understanding a
reasonable assessment of the evidence
over decades of research right so it's
not the case that there is no empirical
research out there there is no empirical
research on on on the multiverse there
is empirical research on paranormal
phenomenon has been going on for decades
actually close to a century and it
hasn't convinced the proper epistemic
community that to me it's a fairly big
failure now could it turn out to be
otherwise in another 50 years sure to
play devil's advocate we have dark
matter I believe was first proposed in
the 1930s we still have no sign of what
it might be so why is it valid to
continue to believe that is a again
pursuing so dark matter well you had the
physicists oh you should really be
answering that I'm gonna give a very
short answer and then if you don't mind
you feel the huge gaps that I'm gonna
leave so dark matter as far as I
understand is essentially a placeholder
since oh it's dark energy it's a
question of look we know that there is
something missing here we know because
we can measure okay we can make
measurements cosmological measurements
and we know that there is something that
it's not there that should be there
there's none enough to account it's not
enough energy not enough matter to
account for the behavior of the universe
as we actually observe it we're gonna
call it dark because we don't see it we
don't know what the hell it is you know
some people have ideas but we don't know
what it is so it's not that one believes
that somebody believes in dark matter
somebody simply believes the observation
to tell us that there is something
missing and then we'll call that missing
thing dark matter am i completely off I
hope no no no that this is it this is it
so there are phenomena that are observed
which are interpreted as dark matter now
nobody knows what dark matter is made of
there are lots of
theories and there are lots of eminent
theoretical physicists who claim that
evidence of no absence of evidence is
not necessarily evident absence of
evidence if I can get that right in the
right way it's not evidence of absence
it's thank you it's because this stuff
is invisible to us it's hard to test and
hard to pin down which is why we know so
little about what this phenomenon that
we've observed actually is in terms of
its nature but there are experimental
observations of something there which
have been interpreted as this so I must
respond to something Massimo said first
of all you said the if telepathy exists
it would overturn existing physics
chemistry and biology I didn't it would
you know when electromagnetic fields
were introduced into science it didn't
overturn Newtonian physics actually
extended science and telepathy concerns
the nature of minds it's not as if
physics chemistry and biology have been
very successfully explaining the nature
of minds or consciousness it's not as if
this is hard science which we can rest
everything on it's the it's called the
hard problem precisely because you know
so little about minds and consciousness
a philosopher calls it the heart problem
and he's wrong but the thing is that
that it's not as if so first of all you
said we have to raise the bar because
physics chemistry and biology I saw the
theory of mind is not solid it's very
disputed and in consciousness studies
there's a wide range of theories about
the nature of consciousness and how it
works some of them are field theories of
minds where minds have fields that
aren't just confined to the brain just
like cellphones have fields that aren't
confined to the phone so what this idea
need a new particle no it wouldn't know
so need a new particle but it would need
connections at a distance of a kind that
might involve an extension of the mind
beyond the brain but the point is that
it wouldn't necessarily imply overturn
existing physics chemistry and biology
there was one of your points the bar
must be much higher the second point is
that all this evidence whose sarin valid
peoples departments get closed down in
the u.s. at the moment there are current
I think two full-time parapsychologists
there are about 100,000 subscribers to
skeptic organizations who if any
parapsychology grant is made by any
university if any public funding body
tried to make one that'd be instant
attacks so and when university to get
endowments for it like the castle of
charity Edinburgh the first person
appointed was a parapsychologist when he
died the academic committee tried to
appoint a skeptic and in fact they have
appointed a skeptic they've downgraded
to a readership and kept the money for
the psychology department this has
happened over and over and over again
within universities so using that as
evidence for lack of prejudice it seems
to me rather distorting no no no no it's
just another example of it review and
Prejudice in action wait a minute I've
wait I never I never said that there is
lack of effort I started out my remarks
by saying that that scientists can be
dogmatic
and sometimes unnecessarily so it's it
again it just comes down to as there
being enough work to convince the proper
community that's really the bottom line
and the answer so far it's clearly no
this is and this is an empirical
question the answer is clearly no right
and so as an outsider if I'm gonna bat
I'm gonna bet against you
yeah but why be why what I can't get is
you know I don't go around denouncing
physical chemistry or denouncing
astrophysics why do people who know
nothing about subjects feel so strongly
they have to form organizations to
denounce it and oppose it I'm going to
leave it there I think I'm very glad we
found some disagreement I think what we
have actually found also some agreement
because one of the questions we were
meant to address is can we have a
science without evidence and I think
everyone up here has given the firm
answer we can't